wirtschaftsexperten fordern jetzt die
rente mit 70 moment mal so lange wollen
wir arbeiten ja wären richtig das ist
der grund für diesen vorschlag der teuer
schock der hat nämlich kein ende laut
bundesbank dürfte unser leben in diesem
jahr im schnitt um 6,9 prozent teurer
werden und die politik ist auch mal
völlig ratlos was sie gegen die höchste
inflation seit 40 jahren tun können da
jetzt dieser vorschlag der
wirtschaftsexperten später in rente
gehen kann diese entwicklung wohl ein
stückchen abfedern und zugeschaltet ist
jetzt bildpolitik chef jan schäfer jan
guten morgen wie geht es dir denn morgen
dank von pc oder
bist du 70 jahre alt bis noch anhalten
muss
also das ist hört sich glaube ich für
viele an wie ein horror aber ich glaube
das ist jetzt gar nichts und das ganz
große problem ihr wissen ja dass wir
alle immer länger leben und wenn man
sich zahlen anguckt was die
rentenbezugsdauer angeht dann stellen
wir fest die hat sich verdoppelt in den
vergangenen 50 jahren den 60er jahren
haben menschen im schnitt in deutschland
zehn jahre rente bezogen mittlerweile
beziehen wir im schnitt rund 20 jahre
rente das heißt wir neben auch immer
länger und das ist natürlich ganz klar
es muss am ende alles finanziert werden
und deswegen müssen wir am ende auch
länger arbeiten als
man in zusammenhang warum wird gerade
denn alles teurer und warum muss ich
daran arbeiten
das ist eine wirklich sehr gute frage
patricia also warum wird derzeit vieles
teurer und das hat ganz unterschiedliche
gründe da spielt natürlich der ukraine
krieg mit rein das spielt aber generell
das problem was wir gesehen haben schon
durch corona das lieferketten zerstört
wurde und deswegen zum beispiel
vorprodukte aus china beispielsweise
nicht rechtzeitig oder verspätet oder
gar nicht in deutschland angekommen sind
und wenn produkte fehlen dann gibt es
immer einen mangel und das bedeutet dass
der preis steigt so das ist die eine
seite der medaille aber was die experten
jetzt vorschlagen und was sie raten ist
denn wenn wir sehen dass bis 2030
beispielsweise fünf millionen
arbeitnehmer in deutschland zählen dann
bedeutet das am ende auch das waren
nicht in vollem umfang hergestellt
werden können oder
das dienstleistung beispielsweise im
pflegebereich oder zb beim friseur
einfach nicht mehr in dem umfang
geliefert und hergestellt werden können
wie man sie braucht und wenn etwas fehlt
bedeutet das in der regel dass die
preise steigen und jetzt ist die
überlegung der ökonom zu sagen wenn wir
fünf millionen arbeitnehmer zu wenig
haben dann lasst uns doch diese lücke
ein kleines bisschen verkleinern indem
wir länger arbeiten und später in rente
gehen in der hoffnung dass dann der
schock ein bisschen abgemildert werden
kann wie gesagt es geht nicht um den
aktuellen teuer schock aber es geht um
das problem steigender preise in der
zukunft aber jan könnte sich die
situation der nicht von alleine wieder
entspannen wenn die pandemie zb
vorübergeht und auch der ukraine krieg
ja aber diese lücke von rund fünf
millionen arbeitnehmern die kann man
ziemlich gut vorausberechnen anhand des
aktuellen
rentensystems wir sehen die ganzen baby
boomer die gehen in den nächsten jahren
in rente und um 1 22 nochmal zu nennen
im jahr 2020 zeit 100 arbeitnehmer in
die rentenkasse ein und finanzierten
damit 37 rentner im jahr 2030 werden 100
arbeitnehmer in die kasse einzahlen und
schon 47 rentner finanzieren wir sehen
also auch dass wir dort für die
rentenkasse ein echtes
finanzierungsproblem haben und jetzt
wollen die rentner natürlich völlig zu
recht ihr geld auch irgendwie ausgeben
wir wollen mal essen gehen die wollen
zum friseur gehen die brauchen ist
möglicherweise auch für arzt
dienstleistung für
pflegedienstleistungen aber wenn es zu
wenig menschen gibt die diese leistungen
die nachgefragt werden auch angeboten
werden steigen automatisch die preise
und das ist die idee der ökonom zu sagen
wir brauchen einfach mehr beschäftigte
und deswegen jedoch bitte etwas später
in rente damit sowohl die rentner als
auch die arbeitnehmer nicht unter einem
teuer schock leiden der in den nächsten
jahren auf uns zukommen wird also ja wir
sind irgendwie selber schuld weil wir
immer älter werden trotzdem ist mir
daran gelegen findest du noch weitere
schuldige die dieses dilemma zu
verantworten haben natürlich also im
prinzip muss man sagen es ist wunderbar
dass wir alle älter werden das ist ganz
toll und jeder rentner der ein leben
lang gearbeitet hat er hat auch ein
leben und eine rente vor allem in würde
verdient aber was in der rentenpolitik
in letzten jahren passiert ist war genau
das gegenteil dessen was notwendig ist
wir haben die rente mit 63 1 geführt
wohl so als beispiel das bedeutet dass
man schon mit 63 unter bestimmten
bedingungen in rente gehen kann es ist
genau der gegenteilige effekte wir
wollen wir wollen ja dass die lücke
eigentlich zwischen denjenigen die wir
brauchen im arbeitsmarkt und denen die
in rente gehen kleiner wird und jetzt
wird sie größer also da ist zum beispiel
etwas passiert was völlig falsch ist und
das ist alles teuer das müssen alles die
arbeitnehmer von heute bezahlen aktuell
wird die rentenkasse mit ungefähr 100
milliarden euro pro jahr aus dem
bundeshaushalt unterstützt das sehen wir
also die rente an sich ist selbst gar
nicht mehr finanzierbar und um hier ein
bisschen auch finanz druck rauszunehmen
ist es ebenfalls notwendig dass wir alle
länger arbeiten also man kann sagen wir
haben ein problem in der zukunft und es
wurde in der vergangenheit viel falsch
gemacht und das kumuliert jetzt und das
muss gelöst werden dank jan schäfer für
diese anordnungen
der jan